من جانبها اكدت الحكومه الالمانيه ضروره
تشكيل لجنه لتهيئه الظروف لوقف دائم
لاطلاق النار كما حذرت من ان التسرع في
اجلاء عمال الاغاثه الالمان والدوليين من
السودان قد تكون له عواقب وخيمه وكانت
الخارجيه الالمانيه قد اكدت ان الجيش
الالماني انها المرحله الاولى من عمليات
الاجلاء
دائما انتهت اليوم بشكل مؤقت رحلات
الاجلاء التي يقوم بها الجيش الالماني من
الخرطوم وهو ما يمثل نهايه المرحله الاولى
من عمليات الاجلاء سنبقي على جهودنا لحل
هذه الازمه تم اجلاء نحو 700 شخص من
السودان نحن وزملائنا في وزاره الدفاع
نعمل يدا في يد في مهمه الاجلاء هذه وقد
وصل الى المانيا نحو 500 من الاشخاص الذين
تم اجلاؤهم من الخرطوم ونتوقع ايضا وصول
نحو 200 شخص هذا اليوم منهم زملائنا
العاملون في بعثاتنا في الخارج